[Music]
ausländisch
das
ähm
zuerst muss ich sagen wie ähm so als
nächstes am genauesten mit dieser debatte
einmal unter euch allen war ich nur
hier um
mein land
anzumelden kämpfe so hart 10
[musik]
[Musik]
ist
ähm, ja, ich sage immer
allen, dass okay, ich bin dankbar
für diese
[Musik]
ist
das
mit den Dokumenten und den
Informationen  von nds und dann alles
äh
du weißt militär und ermittlungen
[musik]
du kennst
konservative
[musik]
meine
ich i ich bin mir sicher kein wort kann erwarten
das ist einsteins demonstration
äh
sicher das das genau was was sie
Ich glaube,
ich bin
äh,
eigentlich weißt du, in dem Moment, als ich mein Land verließ, war
es, als ob du wüsstest, dass ich war, als wäre
ich
[Musik]
Alice
das einzige, was
[Musik]
manchmal
weißt du, dass der Stift größer ist  als dein
geld materialien und es ist der gleiche moment
für mich ist deschamps
aloe vera
[musik]
[musik  ]
Etwas,
ich denke,
es ist nur schwieriger, es mit Worten zu erklären.
Wir werden das nächste Mal niemals oben aufgeben. Oh,
meine Generation, es wird uns
nichts ausmachen. [Musik] [Musik] in einer sehr großen Entfernung von der Stadt, aber die Leute haben gehört, dass die Taliban
sind
in afghanistan
wir
wir die neue generation wir werden nie
vergessen
wer uns das angetan hat
für jetzt ist
es genauso wie du weißt wir werden es versuchen
[musik]
ich kann mir vorstellen wie schwer es war
mein land zu verlassen und in dieses flugzeug
zu
steigen  Musik]
wenn
ist